a lot of people don't grow because they
want money to buy things a lot of
people's businesses don't grow because
they want the business to give them
money so they can get a corvette this is
back to you've got to find the thing you
like
because if you're building a brand or
your thing to buy the yacht
you're not going to build a very big
thing so for me
this thing that we're talking about
i don't want the things that come from
being the best entrepreneur in the world
i just want to be the best entrepreneur
in the world
as content creators in this day and age
it is critical that we have the pulse on
what's actually happening in this world
when it comes to social media youtube
when it comes to scaling your business
how do you actually get out there and
make content that people want to hear in
today's episode we're going to be diving
into some exclusive content that we had
at our annual event grow with video live
where sean cannell and gary vaynerchuk
sat down to discuss things like how
social media and youtube are changing
how tick tock is gunning for everyone
right now and why short form video is
critical for your content strategy right
now i want to welcome you to the think
media podcast my name is heather torres
the host of this show here at think
media where we want to help you grow
your influence using video and then turn
that influence into a high impact and a
high income online business if you're
new to the podcast family we want to
welcome you and ask you subscribe
wherever you're consuming this content
whether it be the audio version or over
on our think media podcast youtube
channel where we have exclusive content
just for you over there so make sure
you're subscribed and every single
tuesday you'll get a brand new upload
plus on our youtube channel we have
additional videos and content like our
industry expert friends that come and
teach as well as short form and other
long-form videos that you don't want to
miss so make sure you're subscribed
wherever you're consuming this content
now today's episode is special to me
because this is someone who i have
personally been following and seeing his
career explode over the last probably
decade when it comes to the online space
this is gary vaynerchuk he was one of
our keynote speakers
at grow with video live 2022. now if
you're unfamiliar with gary vaynerchuk
he's actually a serial entrepreneur and
he serves as the chairman of vaynerx
he's the ceo of vaynermedia and the
creator and ceo of v friends
gary is a new york times bestselling
author of books like crush it the thank
you economy jab jab jab right hook and
his latest book 12 and a half from
starting his first youtube channel in
the basement of his father's liquor
store to creating a massive online
following of over 40 million people
across all the platforms of youtube
tiktok instagram linkedin and facebook
gary's actually one of the leading
experts in online marketing helping
entrepreneurs like you learn how to get
attention online so this is an exclusive
conversation between sean cannell and
gary vaynerchuk that they had at groweth
video live and i do need to say a
disclaimer normally we are a very family
friendly actually we are a
family-friendly podcast but if you know
anything about garyvee you know that he
definitely is abrasive in his language
so if you've got little ones around this
would be the episode where you plug in
those earbuds this is not something i
personally would play in the car around
my kids unless they are age-appropriate
for the language used in this
i believe that everyone can create
content however they'd like but we just
want to make sure that you know that
this is family friendly here at think
media now gary vaynerchuk is going to be
talking
about social media in this context and
he actually did a talk at growth video
where he dove into just the content
strategy that you should be having right
now so this is an extension of that talk
that he gave that sean got to really go
deeper in some of the topics i'm excited
for you to jump into this i'll meet you
on the other side of the content lean in
think media fam and here you go with
gary vaynerchuk
[Music]
let's rock and roll hey
couple questions from the man uh
vaynermedia you're in touch with what's
happening
and uh one of the things that susan the
ceo of youtube put in the letter at the
beginning of the year
was that youtube is talking about
integrating nfts one of the things that
they put out there who knows if they'll
execute
do you have any thoughts about that and
should creators be waiting for that i
mean what would your advice be and do
you think they're going to execute that
well
i'm not sure in the last part because
there's a million things going to that
that i have no clue on i think on the
first part you understand
that last thing i ended with or right
before i ended
like people really like again for the
youngsters this may sound crazy people
really thought the internet was a fad
like actually
right and
i thought everybody would have a website
and every company and they did
social media really was weird like
people really didn't want it to happen
they thought it was awkward they thought
it was stupid they thought it was for
just kids
it's most people have a social network
right that they're involved in there's
not a business on earth that's not going
to have nft infrastructure
it doesn't make any sense it's
technology right now everyone's too
fascinated on the art and the
collectibles part that's a tiny thing
everyone's focused on the art and
collectibles with a hint of utility like
i just did with vcon the nft is a ticket
it's gonna flip
its utilities with a hint of
collectibility
everyone of delta you know your ticket
that might be worth three dollars
because it has some artists on it but
there's a million of them right so
of course they're going to integrate it
there's no alternative
tick tock just made a major move and
they talked about a 50 50 split which
would be the first platform that's
coming for youtube's super generous ad
rev share that has been a major
but i think a reason why creators flock
there it pays the best
right now it's limited to big creators
100 000 and
what do you think in terms of your
predictions and tick tock gun in for
everybody right now
look i think they've done a really good
job i think first of all their algorithm
is based on the interest graph instead
of the social graph which is a huge
advantage and i believe in merit
so my favorite thing is to look at all
your tick tocks where this video got 17
views this one got 430 and this one got
1.9 million that feels like merit
everybody's instagram being around the
same numbers doesn't feel like merit and
so i think we're intoxicated by the
merit of it they've been very aggressive
they've
they've already
won and now they're just going to expand
that's what everybody does right so they
want on this thing now they're saying oh
you can make longer videos oh you can
write more like today i was like wait a
minute i can write more copy i missed
the headlines i've been in like a cocoon
for four months with con and series 2b
friends so they'll just create
everything and so
yeah i mean i think they're incredibly
aggressive they've they tend to they're
still acting like a small company
they're innovating innovating innovating
innovating and now they've got everybody
following them they're the clear leader
in my opinion of the attention graph
which i think is the most important
currency in the world and
i think it's a smart move
if you backstage you said something you
said that short form is a gateway to
long form so what would your strategy be
for that if you're making tick tocks
you're getting the short form reach this
long form substance in your opinion and
does that mean send people off platform
does that mean try to get tick-tock to
get your account to 10 minutes which is
super interesting longer form v
vertical video
what do you mean by short form as a
gateway to long form and what would the
tactics be in that
it means that a lot of long-form
creators don't focus on short form and
vice versa
there's a reason i have one hour keynote
videos and one hour podcast but also
pound unlimited micro content that's 10
seconds long
um you can go very tactical and you know
you know a lot of people want to hear
that like should i make a tick tock that
says watch the rest on youtube it's less
about that people will find you they
become intrigued your url strategy on
all your social networks should be very
thoughtful i'm constantly changing them
based on whatever my objectives are
but it just means that the world of
content creating should be always
thought about as and and i noticed that
everybody's into or
right people are insecure most of you
did not start on tick tock fast enough
because you didn't have followers on it
you didn't start on tick tock fast
enough because you had 80 000 followers
on instagram and you had zero on tick
tock and you didn't like that feeling
that's why celebrities lost the first
time around
so like the things that you made fun of
people for on instagram you became on
tick tock
and so
you know i just i think it's always and
everyone's in order like i'm already on
instagram they love using like logical
excuses like gary i need to focus i'm
like cool
knock yourself out i'll talk to you in
36 months when you're crying
you're focusing on losing
the lack of humility
and the
lack of interest in putting in the work
on a new thing because you just figured
out the last thing is why most people
don't grow
there's not an accident that i've been
winning on every platform for the last
15 years it's called humility and hard
work
you think i was pumped when i had a
million followers on twitter and
instagram came along i was pissed
i'm like i'm winning this bird game
but i'm like everyone's gonna go there
so i need to go
you think i was pumped when
tick-tock came along i was dominating
the gram
i was like that's where it's going to be
so the lack of humility and the lack of
like i don't want to learn this new
thing i just got this that's fine
there's a problem though what you want
has nothing to do with what the market
is doing
the market doesn't give about your
feelings
the market's not like oh tyrone spent a
lot of time on instagram we should not
create tick tock
you think god's thinking like that get
the [ __ ] out of here
gary that's a great lead-in
to uh
but it's like like right it's like the
hypocrisy is hilarious especially within
social you won
on youtube or you want on instagram
doing that to the person that was
holding on to twitter or facebook but
then you're mad when tick tock is doing
it to you
the hypocrisy is deafening
powerful
that's
come on yeah
gary that's a great lead-in to uh by the
way i'm laughing so did you see this no
video hard drive crashed yep got it i
know it's brutal i know right but it's
nice you have to adjust to reality we're
adjusting we got to pivot right now you
wanted some sort of video that's right
hard drive crashed we got a pivot
not a pivot yeah life is life i'm pumped
that you got a blue check on instagram
but here comes tick tock to sit up what
are you gonna do what are you gonna do
you're gonna sit and hope
i'm watching everybody like hope i hope
this tick tock thing doesn't happen all
of you got forced in technology will
beat you
i love all of you that don't think nfts
are coming you will lose
you're pumped at the market's down see
see nothing i'll see you in 2027. let's
go
hey i love this lead into tick tock
there's a lot of people in the room
uh
that are
that are uh they're act they're at a
place where a lot of people doing really
well i mean some people starting out and
you always say if you got you don't got
money but you got time that's what you
got to put the sweat equity in but
there's people in the room they have
money and i'd like to hear about team
garyvee like and a lot of people think
okay to do this because you say i went
on tick tock but part of the way you're
doing that is because people are
multiplying your content you're casting
vision can you speak into maybe
we team gary v is pretty advanced now
yeah can we start a little bit at the
beginning as you think about those that
would say what am i what about my first
hires how do i even do this i'm great at
real estate or financial services but
okay how do i start you know every where
i get my drock where do i get the whole
thing speak to early stages of building
that team to help you grow with video
you need to hire people that do things
that you don't want to do
where do you find them
the internet
people
say things that drive me crazy because
they don't want to do it
as if you can't find it
are you telling me you're at this
conference and you can't find people
you don't know what fiverr is you don't
know how to post on linkedin you don't
know how to search terms on twitter like
people come up with excuses a lot of
people
a lot of people don't grow because they
want money to buy things
a lot of people's businesses don't grow
because they want the business to give
them money so they can get a corvette
or a second this is back to you've got
to find the thing you like
because if you're building a brand or
your thing to buy the yacht
you're not going to build a very big
thing
i'm just building the thing to build a
thing
it's more interesting for me to build
the thing than it is it's like this
some people love actually here's a great
comp this is this blew my mind one of
the most stunning things that happened
to me in my life my whole life
i've wanted to be a professional athlete
right
so
by fifth grade i was like i don't think
i can play for the jets
these kids have gotten much bigger and
stronger in fact i had such good
hand-eye coordination that i was killing
people in first and second and third
grade but somewhere around like fifth
grade i'm like why is everyone twice my
size now
and so i was like this might not be in
the cards and that's when i decided to
buy the jets but
i was like if i can't play for it i'll
just own the whole thing
so now me and aj get into the sports
business and we have a big practice now
and when i realized that a lot of kids
play professional sports but they don't
love the game it was just their best way
to monetize that like blew my mind and i
mean really don't like it and like even
when we recruit kids now i never want to
recruit a kid that doesn't love the game
because i don't think they're going to
be at the you know because we make our
money on the second and third contract
there's kids that sign that first
contract and it's a wrap you want to
know why people are out of the league in
three four years because they didn't
give a [ __ ] about the game so for me
this thing that we're talking about
i don't want the things that come from
being the best entrepreneur in the world
i just want to be the best entrepreneur
in the world
we're going to jump right back into
today's featured conversation but i
wanted to let you know about a brand new
free masterclass and downloadable guide
that's available for you at
21videotips.com if you like content like
this that you're learning from
patrickbetdavid and sean cannell you can
get 21 more video marketing tips from
people like patrickbetdavid vanessa lau
pat flynn alex hermozy and so many
industry experts that are using powerful
strategies for their video marketing
today you're gonna learn the best kept
business secrets inside of this master
class and free downloadable guide so
head over to 21videotips.com
to get instant access for free and learn
how you can level up your business and
brand from today's top industry experts
now let's get back into today's featured
content
so it goes to like do you love it
because if you don't you can't get there
and so a lot of people don't have a
drock or a team because they don't want
to spend the 53 000 on it because they
want to burka bag and they want to go to
tahiti and they want to lambo
you're taking the money out of your
business for your insecurities instead
of feeding the business to win the game
people want to
look successful more than actually be
successful
back to why i make so much content about
self-esteem
the reason i focus on love and being
kind to yourself and the [ __ ] that i've
been talking about is that's the seed of
the whole game
if you need lambos and chains and
accolades and check marks and a million
followers to clog the holes that you
have in your soul
then you're gonna not be able to build
meaningful things because you're taken
out
of your business instead of feeding it
gary for stage two and this is kind of
a personal question
because i'm a case study for it you know
your influence has so i went from
making tech review videos from reviewing
tech doing tech tutorials and affiliate
marketing built a six figure income one
of the biggest pieces of advice as i'm
watching your content and i'm absorbing
is we put it back in we put it back in
my wife and i just looked at the numbers
in 2019 our income went down our net was
like nothing
because we just went and we went all in
team 20 and then in 2020 things forexed
after making a massive investment back
in our business we're now 23 people
um and we're trying to really follow
your model
63 pieces of content a day that free
deck that you have or whatever all of
the numbers i throughout are completely
arbitrary the number
and i need it
i mean it you're talking about the 86
pieces of content you know
yeah 73 four tick tocks a day all of it
all of it's arbitrary the number is as
much as humanly possible
[Applause]
they're more at-bats for attention and
opportunity
you know what's better than 100 push-ups
200.
you like that one huh
but i love you know who i love the most
fitness people fitness entrepreneurs are
my favorite let me tell you why
they're so good at their craft
like right like
but then with the business they don't do
the thing they do in fitness
they like fitness entrepreneurs cheat on
people because people want shortcuts in
fitness they want
implants they want
apple cider vinegar pills they want all
sorts of when the answer is put the work
in the gym and eat properly like follow
the model but then as entrepreneurs you
see these all beefed up did everything
perfect i'm talking about the ones that
don't cheat i'm talking about doing it
right
and then they come to business and
they're like what's the shortcut and i'm
like you know that there's no shortcut
in this
the [ __ ] are you looking for shortcut in
this
right
it they fascinate me because they have
such a big chapter of their life they
know everyone's like
i spent 38 years looking for the
shortcoming like
they're like it's
go in the gym and eat properly
amen
so
back to content i'm like i don't know
like some of you make really good tick
tocks but you don't do this like you
have to be contextual to the platform
you have to know who the audience is and
slang matters
right you have to understand you have to
put in the reps the content output like
you know everybody tries to use social
as distribution they make one piece of
content and post it everywhere that
completely doesn't work
you've got to contextualize and post
creative for the platform i've i've
given three talks today
flew in that's why i was able to make it
work with vikon i'm super pumped about
surrounding this and i surrounded it all
three are different i have to read the
room
the kind you know the
philosophical it's the same but it's got
to be different
right
it's like cuisine it's all food but it's
different
and you have to know your audience i
don't understand how people come with
youtube dna into tick tock and think
it's going to work the mindset's
different the same person the same human
i'm not talking about age and gender and
race and religion the same human being
is a different consumer
on tick-tock than they are on instagram
your mindset's different one's passive
entertainment on linkedin it might be in
for me like it's all context
so level two garyvee
uh teamgaryvee yes and and so
uh
maybe break down i'm looking taking
advantage of a little bit of advice how
you built the team how fast you're
trying to scale the team do you have
people running operating things editors
uh i mean
at this point everything you know i and
maybe some people that are really paying
attention my content's a little bit down
because be friends and vayner x is
exploding and i'm like uh there's a lot
for me to do there but yeah i mean you
know i film everything yeah i film
absolutely everything and then we go
into post-production
and we script the audio for the podcast
and we and we have writers who take the
words like everything is me even you
know everything has to be me how many
people taking by the way that's a real
big point anybody here
who has a social media person post on
their behalf and write the copy
to this day
every single word
every single word on instagram twitter
tick tock every single word
in the copy is written actually by me
i know people who like
immediately hire someone to post on
their behalf and write the copy as if
it's them
that's that apple cinegar
gummies
[Applause]
so obviously i don't make the videos
but like half the videos in my whatsapp
with my team right now never get posted
because i don't like it
half
i don't like it
i think they missed the context i think
it's out of context i don't want to talk
about that right now because the world
is this that
and then i post it me
so
you know i think that people don't want
to do the work but you can have tons of
people around you we
figured out document don't create that
was the big unlock
just film everything post produce
this is a good reason to start shows if
you look go you know this might really
help a lot of you go to youtube tonight
when you get back home put in my name
and sort by lowest views you will be
blown away how many little things i do
and have done no audience because i
wanted just the content from doing the
podcast
for my post-production
so like at this point in my career it's
awesome because i get to win twice back
in the day i would do it because i
wanted the content
now it's like a double win because i
know me being on a guest on an up and
coming show really helps them so i'm
giving love and roses and i'm getting my
content but a lot of you say no to
because your humility's not in check
i still say yes that a lot of you pass
on
because i out humble you
gary i have one more walking around here
like i'm only gonna do joe rogan you
suck right now
what are you talking about you should do
everything
one is greater than zero
one is greater than zero i watch people
walk around thinking there's somebody
you know i got there was somebody at
vcon trying to get into somebody they're
like yo i got 18 000 followers on
instagram like what the f
people get high on their own supply real
quick
real quick people walking around here
thinking there's somebody because they
got 230 000 followers on tick tock so
humble the [ __ ] up
we'll get better
all right some like you know i just hope
everybody knows
no i just realized it's important i just
really i want everybody know that's not
me razzing that's me loving you
i see a lot of people saying no as if
there's somebody
you want to really win decide you're
nobody everything gets real interesting
real fast after that
gary one of the big things that holds
people back is
self-consciousness but specifically
people that worry about how am i going
to look on camera how am i going to
sound on camera uh what would you say to
somebody who's just trembling with fear
to get on camera because of those
insecurities i say a lot of things it's
the core foundation of my content
the last seven years of my life have
been dedicated on trying to build
people's self-esteem
i sound crazy
not all that great i mean i've gotten a
little bit better looking but like you
know like
i'm not winning on that
like so
like i don't like high school ended
everybody has zits too
like you know like people are like like
i'd laugh when i was like yo you really
suck at this i'm like you suck too
as if not everybody sucks at ya
everybody in here sucks that's so much
it's crazy
right
and but you want the i'll give you a
real answer to what i actually think
works
this is a wild answer to this in my
opinion but i really started to zero in
i'm going to help you
jump over to hurdle the fear of how i
look how i sound
deploy compassion to those who [ __ ] on
you
i think the reason i'm winning is when
somebody says you're an idiot you're a
scam you're full of
you suck you're ugly you
my my brain immediately goes to like man
for somebody to take time out
of their day
to come to my profile
to try to tear me down because they're
hurting so much inside i only have love
for them
i'm aware that we're in a societal place
right now where the way we respond to
people's hate is with hate back to them
but i just don't have that gear when i
get [ __ ] on i deploy love through the
form of compassion if you're able to do
that
you won't hear them
but that's why i've been pounding on
humility the reason i work is because
i've got this going on
for when i get a thousand comments
860 of them are a goat emoji
the other 140 are you're a scam artist
when you can't hear either you can move
when you only hear the goat stuff you
become vulnerable to the scam stuff
too many people want that affirmation
and that's why people become unhappy if
your values are based on people giving
you accolades then you become
susceptible to the teardown
i'm just attached to both
can't hear you i'm on the field the [ __ ]
am i going to worry about you cheering
or booing i'm on the field you're eating
popcorn
you're making videos you're putting in
work you're trying to win for yourself
you're worried about sally pants 97 in
arkansas who's pissed
her
well if there's one thing garyvee can do
it's give you the kick in the pants to
create more content i hope you enjoyed
that content there and i for me
personally listening to that it just
really affirms the idea that we just
need to be creative creating more i love
how he said it's not or it's not long
form or short form it's not youtube or
tiktok it's ant because we live in a
world where attention matters and one of
the key things that i took away was that
it needs to just 10x your content needs
to 10x and it needs to be relative to
the platform that you're putting it on
and i know as a busy entrepreneur this
is probably something that you're
thinking how do i get this done what do
i do and you know here at think media we
want to help you with that we want to
help you hire the right team we want to
help you learn how to use all the
equipment that you're doing want to help
you figure out great systems and
processes so that you could be making
content and i just love so much how gary
just has a fire for making content
matter and i hope that was encouraging
to you and we'll have additional
episodes just like this with some more
of our key speakers from girl with video
live so make sure you're tuned in here
on the podcast subscribe to wherever you
subscribe
and hit the like button if you like
content like this
here on our show now every single week
my favorite part is getting to read the
reviews of how this podcast is impacting
you personally and you can leave a
review over on apple podcasts and when
you do that you might get featured on
one of our shows today's feature comes
from the marshall walker marshall walker
says i've hit a gold mine heather and
sean are the most motivational speakers
i've ever heard you can tell they really
want their listeners to win and succeed
they practice what they preach and are
amazing at what they do they've helped
me so much with my channel and i don't
know what i would do without them
cheering me on ugh marshall that
literally is going to give me life for
this next week thank you so much for
leaving that review and sharing your
heart i have how this podcast has helped
you personally i really do hope that the
content we're giving you here is
valuable and is worth your time because
i know that your time is limited and i
want to make sure that you are getting
all the value that you can now if you
did not already go to 21videotips.com
that's where you can go if you want to
hear more tips like this for free from
people like gary vaynerchuk
patrickbetdavid vanessa lau pat flynn
and so many other industry experts when
it comes to sharing their secrets of
growing your brand online you can go to
21
videotips.com you can get that free
masterclass as well as the free
downloadable uh content that goes along
with it i highly recommend that you go
there now get that and dive into those
21 additional tips of how to grow this
year thank you so much for being a part
of what we're doing here at think media
leave a comment down below in youtube
and if you're watching right now i just
like put thumbs up because
that's what you should do thumbs up the
youtube video and uh thank you so much
for listening i will catch you in the
next episode bye
[Music]
you